hi everybody say sir Ronald welcome
thank you we're delighted to have you
with us here today and so there's many a
budding entrepreneur here in the
audience who would be quite satisfied if
they had the one successful venture
under their belt you've not only
successfully co-founded five to date and
Counting but also established multiple
sectors along the way but this wasn't
without encountering many a skeptic so
can you talk us through how you
calibrate the extent to which you should
have courage of your own convictions and
ignore the naysayers versus engage them
and take heed of their warning so the
best way is to start young yeah and ie
then think big and then stick with it I
think with advancing years you become
more skeptical some become cynical and
my experience has been in developing
venture capital and then private equity
and now impact investment that you
should focus on those who are
enthusiastic first who get it don't need
convincing
then those who's skeptical and you
should just avoid the cynics because
those who believe that nothing nothing
new can be done or that nothing should
be done firm for the first time are
plentiful in your in our society and Eve
you've been involved in impact
investment and you know that it isn't
something that everybody immediately
picks up nevertheless it's the future
and I've just come from Mexico in Merida
which is an hour and a half away from
Mexico City four hundred people gathered
from 20 Latin American countries to talk
about impact investment and that's just
one indication I was in Brazil and six
hundred people came to a meeting on on
impact investment and when you meet with
government officials you find people are
aware of the fact that society can not
Tinh you to tackle social issues in the
way that we're doing and social for me
includes environmental and so we've come
a long way since 2000 and when you find
an idea that makes sense you think of it
becoming global you begin to attract
inspired people when you think small and
deal with the sceptics you don't tend to
attract inspired people and the people
who are flocking it's not an
exaggeration to impact investment and
now are the best and the brightest and
you're an example need it's very kind of
your page and earlier to say that and
but on the point of skeptics some
critics of the valley accused of being
too insular preferring specialists and
lacking in diversity yeah
given that you successfully transferred
ideas between geographies very PACs
and between sectors with big society in
social finance what do you what extent
you encourage the students here to be
polymaths take the scenic route and have
a multi-faceted career versus kind of
playing to their strengths earlier on
and focusing so could I answer that by
just going through some of my life
history and and then I'll I'll explain
perhaps I'll answer your question
directly so the reason I got into
venture capital is that the speaker came
to the business school general Daurio
who had been professor of
entrepreneurship I guess you'd call it
today at Harvard Business School the
other place and general Daurio unlikely
figure you might think a French military
leader was one of the first venture
capitalists he invested in Dec and in
the discussion he had rather as I'm
speaking to all of you today he said
look I put $70,000 in debt which was
digital equipment company and it's going
public and my stakes going to be worth a
hundred million dollars and that caught
my attention for fedora that's rather
that's new new and interesting at the
time when I was at a business school the
plum jobs were working for IBM or any of
the big General Motors any other big
corporations as small was not yet
beautiful but you felt that something
was in the air Intel had just been
created there was a buzz around
semiconductors and I felt at that time
as I feel today that there was something
in the air which was going to be major
and I decided to go into venture capital
now it was a hard slog venture capital
in those days
in the UK people couldn't spell the word
entrepreneur let alone the word venture
capitalists thing you know so it's
French so when we try to and this is a
true story but one of my venture
capitalists French took his kid to
interview in a school for a position in
the school to join the school and the
headmaster asked the son said them you
know Sonny what does your father do he
said oh he's an adventure copy list
so it was Brad it was brand-new you
couldn't even spell it even though some
kids had innovative minds as you can see
and and I decided at that time
look this is big enough and important
enough that I'm I left McKinsey after
just two two years I'm gonna make a go
of this and I think I think this is the
future now if you connect with something
which you feel is going to be that then
you don't need you don't need a very
long run-up for it I don't need to say
that in Silicon Valley which you know
has led the way in in you know young
entrepreneurs transforming transforming
the world and I think when one talks in
terms of should one devote one's time to
impact investment will talk about the
two strands of impact investment which
are developing the one which has to do
with the funding of not-for-profits and
the one that has to do with the funding
of profit with purpose companies if you
can connect with something that you
think has real potential in these areas
then you should connect with it and get
on with it
if you're unsure about whether or not
you've connected with something like
that then you're better off pursuing
your career and acquiring more
experience until you do that and even in
the not-for-profit sector where today a
social organization can build a balance
sheet in the same way that a business
can that's what impact investment has
done it's provided layers of capital for
not-for-profits the purpose of it was to
connect social entrepreneurs to the
capital markets and we've done that it's
an evolution in the idea that we've got
to do more than just make money but it's
a revolution in the means that we have
brought to not-for-profits seeking to
scale so that they can tackle social
issues effectively and if previously we
have all assumed that nothing
can be measured in the social area and
of course that's true in the sense of
valuing an improvement in a prisoner's
life one improvement in a homeless
person's life
or an improvement in a diabetic or
pre-diabetic life any of the twelve
social issues that are now being
addressed by the fifty-five social
impact bonds which have have been
launched
you can't value that but you can measure
in percentage terms and improvement
versus the past or versus a control
group of people who haven't been helped
and when you link that to a financial
return which represents only a fraction
of the saving to government usually in
the first year then you have something
that is extremely powerful you begin to
have the tools to build an organization
that's motivated to help others in the
same way that you can an organization
that is there to make money so on this
idea of inclusive capitalism and this
idea around engaging the invisible heart
of the markets to create opportunities
for those invisible hands left behind
you're clearly a proponent of business
and market solving these social issues
but are there any areas whereby you
think markets actually can't solve for
and then why is that so the answer is
that not everything can be measured in
the way that I have described there are
lots of social issues which will
continue to be tackled by
not-for-profits through grants we're not
trying to displace grants what we're
trying to do Nev is we're trying to do
what we did for business in areas which
improve society and the planet we're
trying to connect social entrepreneurs
to capital which enables them to harness
entrepreneurship and innovation and when
in 2000 I was
by the Treasury as Charles mentioned to
look at the question of poverty in
Britain and I started to look at how
society has dealt with social issues I
discovered some astonishing things I
discovered that really philanthropists
were the first to tackle social issues
not governments in the 19th century they
began to organize themselves as
foundations which got tax breaks at the
beginning of the 20th century when all
the big foundations or many of the big
foundations now there are much bigger
ones being set up but many of the
household named foundations of the Ford
Foundation Rockefeller Foundation and
the mid thirties the Wellcome foundation
in in the UK were set up by the 1930s
governments were realizing that
philanthropies couldn't cope with social
issues those who were being left behind
as economic growth propelled most of us
forward needed help from the government
and they started to get governments
started to get involved directly in
improving lives by the 1940s we came to
the welfare state which took on the
responsibility for creating a safety net
for citizens who were more vulnerable
and today welfare states are throwing
their hands up across the world they
look at a gap a yawning gap between the
provision of social services their
ability to pay for that and likely
social needs with an ageing population
where the ageing poor is a real
challenge in the future and so the idea
came to us then on the social investment
task force venture capital was a
response to the needs of technical
preneur it was a major innovation
creating ten-year illiquid funds in
order to fund dropouts with vision was
really a new concept
and why can't we find a similar response
to the needs of social entrepreneurs who
are motivated by empathy to help others
and I felt as did my colleagues on the
social investment task force so the way
to do that was to create a social
investment bank that would bring
together people from the financial world
and people from the social world and
innovate in making that connection well
if you fast forward that you know Neve
10 years in 2010 to young people at
social finance which was founded in the
basement of my office in Portland Place
we don't have garages for startups in
the UK we have basements it has the
advantage that the only way out of the
basement is up so an increased level of
motivation and these two young people
came to me and said we were talking to
people in Birmingham in the UK about
prisoner reoffending more than 60% of
prisoners incarcerated before the age of
21 in the UK and in every other country
go back to prison within 18 months and
we came up with the idea of connecting a
reduction in the percentage that goes
back to a financial return I said wow
that is the key to the capital markets
for social entrepreneurs and then as we
began to work on it with the Ministry of
Justice and we started pushing numbers
we began to realize that the cost of the
intervention and it's one of the
essential drivers of impact investment
the cost of prevention is a fraction of
the saving that government makes and so
we created the first social impact bond
in 2010 in just three months and we
found ourselves creating a revolution in
the way that prisoners are dealt with
does it occur to any of us that prison
management across the world has no
responsibility for the reoffending great
it's unbelievable prison management has
responsibility for the cost per prisoner
and the number of incidents in prison
it's unbelievable and when you look at
the way that the social sector the
not-for-profits help prisoners which is
what we had to do we raised five million
pounds to fund four not-for-profits
you realize that not-for-profits have
grown haphazardly dealing with a
specific bit of the chain to achieve an
outcome to simplify one not-for-profit
is helping prisoners imprison ones
helping them at the gate one's helping
them get into a job one's helping them
stay in a job no one has responsibility
for achieving the outcome and when you
begin to give five million pounds to say
let's reduce the rate by seven and a
half percent plus because below seven
and a half percent the social impact
bond doesn't pay back doesn't get paid
back it's just a philanthropic donation
let's get a reduction between seven and
a half and a 15% reduction so that our
investors can make 2 to 13 percent
return on their on their investment you
begin to focus on developing the
necessary information in the same way
that management by objectives forty
years ago got businesses to create
dashboards and key performance
indicators you begin to do the same you
begin to push for understanding how you
deal with the accommodation problem that
40% of prisoners face they don't know
where they're going to spend the night
the 18% that still have a drug habit the
25% that has insufficient money to make
it through to the first government
paycheck and so what's happening is a
prisoner gets to the prison gate with
those three issues
and the drug dealer meets them at the
gate and says come I'll give you a place
to sleep and something to forget what
you've been through and they're back in
two thirds of them are back in prison I
take this example because the cost of
intervention is probably about a third
of the saving the government makes in
the first year the investors in the
first social impact bond will make seven
percent the government has chained the
whole of the probation office not
necessarily in the best way possible
but partly as a result of the focus on
on prisoners which and prisoner
rehabilitation which the social impact
bond brought and so when you look at 55
social impact bonds today across the
world across a dozen countries two were
announced in the last few days in the
United States a 30 million dollar South
Carolina social impact bond to prevent
teenage pregnancies or reduce teenage
pregnancies a 12 and a half million
dollar social impact bond in Connecticut
dealing with unstable families plagued
by drug abuse when you begin to look at
how homelessness is being tackled how
dropout rates from primary school in
India is being tackled how dropout rates
from computer studies at college level
in in Israel is being tackled when you
look at unemployed youth in the UK and
the way that social impact bonds have
funded organizations that help them
acquire the skills to get into jobs you
begin to feel that this is really
bringing about a revolution in the way
that we tackle social issues but as you
know Nev it's only the beginning of the
revolution and and on that point so how
do you see the sector as a whole
evolving going forward what are the new
models that are emerging and who are the
key players that are driving change
today you know the next goal immediate
build race in yourself so
the social impact bond brought us to the
realization that measurement is actually
central to tackling social and
environmental issues and that you can
connect it to a financial return and
access the capital markets that there
are investors who will say wow seven
percent uncorrelated return with stock
markets and interest rates because you
don't know what the bond is going to pay
until later in its life that's pretty
cool people would put five ten percent
of their portfolio in absolute return
instruments of this kind but when we
created the g8 task force and we had 200
people across the world involved through
national advisory boards mad panic of
media was one of my close partners in in
this effort and people like Matt and
Tracy Bohlen dronov of social finance
who together led the national advisory
board in in the United States people
like that across the g7 countries plus
Australia brought all of their know-how
about social issues and finance to the
task force and we realized that
something much more fundamental was
happening than just innovating with an
instrument we realized then that the
world had shifted if in the 19th century
the world measured financial return
Adams Mithen and and before all the way
through to the 19th century in the 20th
century we had innovated by measuring
risk and return and by opening the
window on risk we created a need for new
concepts like diversification which led
to the notion which the endowments are
led including Stanford that you can
include in a diversified portfolio high
risk assets which may be a bit more
volatile but yield much better returns
and improve the
on your portfolio then in the 21st
century we were already measuring risk
return and impact only people haven't
realized it fully those who are
unpopular today be they in the financial
services area or utilities like
electricity generation companies are
unpopular because they're perceived as
having negative impact on society a
utility per se is not an unpopular
company but a utility which is deemed to
charge its customers more than it should
if they are poor and to account for a
big percentage of their disposable
income is judged negatively and when you
begin to measure impact alongside risk
and return you open the window again on
a new set of opportunities themes in the
profit with purpose area for instance
such as the gym in the UK or TOMS shoes
in the United States or Warburg a Warby
Parker or st when my colleagues at
bridges started to look at how could we
improve the health of people living in
poor areas the answer was we should
create gyms but if you create a gym in a
poor area it has to be open 24/7
it has to be large because you're going
to charge a quarter of what you can
charge in the mainstream economy so it's
a 15,000 square-foot gym no membership
fee and no frills no changing rooms no
jacuzzi no spa the gym floated for 250
million pounds just a few months ago in
the UK several thousand members are
joining before the gym opens 30 to 40%
of the members have never been able to
afford the gym before so what's the
window you're opening you're opening a
window on themes that say if I come up
with a product or a service at a low
cost
which is capable of satisfying huge
latent demand I can grow faster than a
mainstream business and so what is
beginning to happen today is that the
measurement of risk return and impact is
beginning to lead to a revolution in the
types of business models that
entrepreneurs are developing and these
two streams the funding of
not-for-profits to achieve social goals
which works better when the community's
help is required in rehabilitating a
prisoner or muna or absorbing a homeless
person and the other stream of profit
with purpose which works better where
you're developing products and services
that can generate cash flow and take
advantage of high growth those two
streams are coming together at the same
time as social and environmental are
coming together and we're beginning to
see governments across the world saying
we can't cope
we need money from the capital markets
it's entrepreneurs we're going to come
with innovation in how we tackle social
issues we're going to fund prevention
that we need to bring in and Sur country
by country we're beginning to see
government's introducing incentives for
this so regarding governments by their
very nature their transitional both in
terms of the stakeholders and the agenda
so how do you ensure that you've managed
to maintain momentum and push your
initiatives through to completion given
all the the ongoing change well that's
the great strength of instruments like
social impact bonds because as Ian
Duncan Smith one of our senior ministers
in government today in charge of the
Department of works and pensions put it
when you sign up for a social impact
bond you get what's written on the tin
as he puts it
the way he expresses it is look I come
in as a minister I have great intentions
I want to make something happen we
developed the idea some of my officials
who always wanted to do something
specific tried to add it in some of my
officials who hate something take it out
and then there's an election and I'm
gone and the program continues badly
designed for decades
and nothing much comes from it with a
social impact bond when you sign a
contract with investors to put money up
on the basis of which there are social
metrics which are going to mean that you
your performance is objectively audited
and you're paid out according to that
you can't deviate from it it has to run
the seven years or the five years or the
ten years of the social impact bond and
it's the way for us to create benchmarks
and innovate in the way that we tackle
social issues so as to improve the
delivery of government services it's not
a substitute for government it's it's an
instrument where government most of the
time pays out on results sometimes
foundations will pay out on results
sometimes health management
organizations will pay out sometimes
universities will pay out as in the
computer studies drop out example but
fundamentally you're innovating in the
way we tackle social issues and you're
setting benchmarks which government then
can take into account in formulating its
own its own policy some of the issues
today sadly are just so complex the
current refugee crisis being one of them
now
given all of your success to date many
here may not know how you arose to be in
the UK to go on to Oxford and beyond and
as I think the story is especially
poignant with this backdrop of the
refugee crisis so I was wondering if
you'd be so kind as to kindly share with
us why your family fled Egypt and what
it was like as an 11 year old boy
arrived
in Britain speaking no English ten
pounds in the pocket and just a suitcase
each sorry well it was interesting I had
my stamp collection under my arm and I
was very worried that it would be taken
away from me as I was leaving Egypt I
have very good memories of Egypt as a
very liberal place I went to a Catholic
school where on Fridays you could go to
the Catholic service or the Muslim
service or the Jewish service
it was the Frye's of son John the
Baptist one of the best schools in Egypt
and the reason that we were kicked out
of Egypt is there was something called
the Suez Crisis which might seem like
the dim and distant past to many of you
it occurred in 1956 when NASA
nationalized NASA who was then the
president of Egypt nationalized the Suez
Canal and Britain which owned the canal
France which built it and Israel which
felt threatened by NASA United to take
the canal and the United States under
pressure from Russia intervened and
stopped that operation and NASA
retaliated by expelling all British and
French citizens and made it very
uncomfortable for Jews to stay basically
and if you an Egyptian Jew as as I was
and my family was then when you left you
lost your Egyptian nationality and there
were only three places that would take
you as a stateless citizen Brazil Canada
and Australia but my mother had a
British passport by a quirk of fate and
we were on our way to Rio de Janeiro and
we stopped in Milan to catch the boat in
Genoa to Rio de Janeiro and my mother
said I'm going to my dad I'm gonna he
couldn't travel because he was stateless
so I'm going to take the kids and go to
London and say goodbye to my brothers
and when she got to London she found my
dad and said we're staying right here
this is where you're going to get the
best education for the kids this is the
place to be what are we going to do in
Brazil miles away from Europe and so on
so for my dad spoke English happily
agreed it was difficult for him to
disagree with my mother who was a very
very forceful person and so we became
British we're delighted to have adopted
you I've been I've been blessed to be
British and Britain has been extremely
good to me
and one interesting quirk is that the
Henry fellowship which I dropped to
Harvard Business School from Oxford
obligated me to come back to Britain
with something of value and the thing I
came back with was venture capital from
Harvard Business School so these things
these things matter so what was it like
well my parents turned it into a
challenge my dad was very sad to lose
everything in Egypt and my mother who
was more down to earth thought Egypt was
going to have a very difficult time and
that this was a blessing in these guys
which it turned out it turned out to be
so I viewed it as a I viewed it deserve
as a challenge and happened to be a good
student and actually the education I had
had in this Catholic school stood me in
good stead and so I made it into Oxford
because of one teacher a history teacher
Richard Richard Farley a history teacher
who said to me Kevin you should be going
to Oxford and he prepared me for the
entrance exams in those days you had a
series of entrance exams that school had
only sent one person to Oxford before
and Richard Farley trained the few of us
and four of us got into Oxford
the real-life case of the history buoys
absolutely and then and I looked for hit
for Richard Farley for years and I found
him 40 years after I left I left or
enjoyed grammar school because I
remembered he'd written a book on
education and that his publisher must
have his address and sure enough that
was the case and so I was privileged to
reconnect with him and visit him once or
once or twice a year I was most
wonderful just the most wonderful man so
when he talked of the immigrant crisis I
have empathy not that I had to go
through the tribulations of the Syrian
immigrants that we see today by the way
another quirk of fate my grandparents
were born in a leper
in Syria and came down to Egypt when the
Suez Canal was opened because the
Caravan routes going through Aleppo died
and all the merchants went into the
Lebanon or or or to Egypt and I think
that we have an obligation to deal with
displaced people not just because we
don't have the choice of ignoring it you
can't have millions of people spreading
through a society not being looked after
without terrible implications for
society but I think it's a moral
obligation we have to help those in need
and one of the efforts are making is to
create at central level at the in the EU
a billion dollar fund to pay out on
social impact bonds which are going to
fund organizations that can help the
absorption of immigrants I mean another
body that you've created is a Portland
trust which seeks to encourage private
sector in both Israel and Palestine as a
means to peace in the Middle East yeah
can you talk us through how business can
or should help resolve conflict
but there are two people in the audience
of fear Samson and Travis Hollingsworth
affair worked with me in Israel at the
Portland trust and Travis worked with me
at big society capital and I think you
know they are examples of people who
feel that one can make a difference by
following these approaches and that you
can do good and do well at the same time
the innovation that is coming now is
coming because there are very powerful
drivers as I have said governments on
the one hand don't have the money a
millennial generation of which you're a
part that feels it wants to do more than
just make money and investors who to the
tune of fifty five trillion dollars have
signed up to the United Nations
principles of responsible investment
saying we owe it to generate more than
just financial returns and social sector
organizations not-for-profits that say
to themselves we want to grow if we're
helping 700 homeless people in the UK
we'd like to help 7,000 there are 30,000
or 50,000 homeless people at any given
time in in the UK these are powerful
drivers and I think the fundamental
change that has come is to say the
allocation can't be on the allocation of
resources in financial terms in terms of
the human capital that you all represent
here today cannot come just on the basis
of risk and return I think being a
business that's in it for just money is
not going to be a popular business
already if you want to attract the
greatest talent in places like McKinsey
and elsewhere you have to elevate the
goals you have to give the opportunity
to entrance to do things that are going
to
proved society and so the transformation
that is going to come through business
is going to start as the tech revolution
did is going to start with the
disruptors who are young and who say I'm
going to create a business which is
going to deliver the best combination of
risk return and impact and I'm going to
attract the most talented people because
it's a more inspiring ago and it's it'll
pull behind their justice tected the big
corporates some of which are reacting
today I was at the launch of a hundred
and twenty-five million euro impact fund
launched by the Mars Corporation and the
Danone Food Corporation in France two
huge food corporations to take a million
people in their supply chain out of
poverty Unilever is beginning to publish
a set of social objectives for itself as
a company and big companies will follow
if you look ahead twenty years
I know Einstein said the future is
unknowable but it's not unthinkable so
let's think as we think together look
ahead twenty years we can envisage
impact public equities impact fixed
income impact venture capital impact
private equity impact real estate and
impact absolute return where will the
money go if investors then have the
choice between a company that delivers a
twenty percent IRR as an investment and
another company that delivers a twenty
percent IRR and a 35 percent social
return measured because governments
publish as the UK is already doing the
cost of social issues on the web you go
to the Cabinet Office website you will
find the cost of six hundred and forty
social issues you'll be able to work out
that the young prisoner I was talking
about is costing the government
twenty-two
thousand pounds a year and if you
rehabilitate a thousand it's 22 million
and 22 million on a five million social
impact bond over seven years is more
than 35 percent rro or whatever where do
you think the money is going to go is it
going to go to those who are just
building a business to make money or is
it going to go to those who are able to
deliver a social return or an
environmental return at the same at the
same time so that's why we called our
report of the g8 task force the
invisible heart of markets because the
invisible heart of markets is the
measurement of impact and it will guide
their invisible hand and there's a
wonderful historic historic element and
it is that Adam Smith was prouder of his
book the Theory of Moral Sentiments
which is all about why people helped out
of empathy than he was out of the wealth
of nations and if he'd been around he'd
have coined the phrase the invisible
heart of markets wonderful so on the
note of thinking the future and getting
our collective minds together we'll turn
to the audience for any questions that
you may have so Gracie and Mario will be
roaming with the mic so you can just put
up your hand and and they'll come to I
think Charlie's got one of the back
there straight off the bat then the mic
will come to you in one second
thank you very much for the words I did
my undergrad at Exeter College as well
and so benefits are real your support
there so thank you for that too
my question was was about your political
views and I guess based on your your
close link to the Labour Party in the UK
whether the advancement of impact
investing had changed those views a in
terms of of what it means for the role
of the government and B with how
receptive different political parties
are to it great to meet somebody who's
an exxorian
as I am I until the Brits just amongst
you
I got a lot to Exeter College you can
imagine what it's like seven years after
coming to Britain as a refugee to walk
into the quad of a college founded in
1314 with illustrious people who'd gone
there before was a real privilege well
I start when I was a student at Oxford
where I was very involved in politics I
was president of the Oxford Union which
is the debating society as a liberal I
was a liberal for 30 years the Liberals
were in the center between the Labour
Party and the Conservative Party when
Tony Blair came in I became a Labour
Party supporter because he adopted the
policies that I believed them and when
David Cameron came in the the Cameron
government called me and said will you
come and lead the social investment and
another social investment task force
will you come to set up the social
investment bank that you recommended in
2000 and if you do and you can put
together an intelligent plan for a
social investment bank we will allow you
to take all of the unclaimed assets you
asked for we had focused in 2005 on
asking the government who was then
trying to take away bank accounts that
had been separated from their owners for
15 years or more from the banks the
banks have hold onto this money and the
Labour government had said to me we'll
give you 75 million pounds rather than
the 250 million pounds you are asking
for as equity for this bank and we said
well we'll start with a couple of
million pounds of philanthropic money
while you think about it because 75
million pounds ain't a lot of money in
financial terms when you're dealing with
the social issues we're talking about to
cut a long story short the Conservative
government allowed us to start the first
social investment bank independent of
government with just one government
representative at the trust level which
- keeping it on mission with the six
hundred million pounds a billion dollars
of which four hundred million pounds
came from unclaimed assets and I found
the Conservative government was
completely sold on the idea of the Big
Society which was basically saying you
have the government it can't cope you
need the society to do it only we didn't
know how society could do it and the
social investment bank was the first
tangible expression of what the big
society program really was so then I
began to work very closely with the
Conservative government and I like to
say that I'm about policy rather than
politics and this issue of impact
investment whether it's in the United
States where the to social impact bonds
were launched in a democratic state and
the Republican state or whether it's in
the UK we've managed to keep it as a
bipartisan issue and to stress for those
who like market forces and for those who
on the other hand feel that the state
should be responsible for all of these
things that this does both it improves
government and it brings
entrepreneurship and capital and market
forces to tackling social issues since
dave is a Bray's news chat from Oxford
as am i I'm happy you gave him a shout
out and next question okay hi my name is
Mario Mexican how do you think about the
different the line that divides what is
impact investing and what it's not to me
you know any business that makes profit
is creating jobs is creating innovation
and advancing society yeah many things
could be argued against tobacco alcohol
it would not be yeah like how do you
think about that line so there's a big
distinction we made in the g8 task force
report between investment with impact
and impact investment we're all in favor
of investment with impact businesses
that create jobs improve lives in their
communities but that's not going to deal
with social issues in the way we need
impact investment is investment where
you have measurable social or
environmental goals set and you measure
their achievement alongside financial
return and that is going to create the
innovation that will lead to a
revolution and so we see impact
investment sitting between philanthropy
on the right hand side which will begin
to measure much more as it gives grants
but will see its own business model
disrupted I will talk about that in a
moment and what we might call ESG
environmental social government
governance on on the left-hand side or
socially responsible investment or CSR
we're basically businesses intend to do
good but don't set measurable objectives
and measure their treatment intention is
not enough we're living in a time when
intention has evolved and the intention
just to make money is no longer
sufficient you need to do more than that
but the revolution is coming by bringing
the means that didn't exist before to
tackle social issues and so I think what
we're going to find over time is that
those businesses in the middle which are
businesses that set social and
environmental as well as financial
objectives and those not-for-profits
that innovate by creating measurable
goals through social impact bonds and in
other ways will bring the innovation
required to improve people's lives and
that will begin to affect the businesses
and the philanthropists on the other
side one of the great parallels for me
who lived through the tech revolution
and Silicon Valley has scored most of
the goals but we invested in the company
in that revolution that cloned Dolly the
sheep in the UK it's one of the only
companies out of Europe that made it to
the hundred most important companies of
the 20th century we lost all our money
but it was a great it was a great thing
to do it's bringing a revolution in in
medicine I think we're going to find
people now who say I want to be the
Microsoft of improving education or I
want to be the apple of improving health
and I'm going to innovate in in the way
that that I do it the disruption that is
happening is right across all the
constituencies of our of our world
so when Jeff Raikes who was CEO of the
Gates Foundation says the business model
of philanthropy is being disrupted what
does he mean he means in the future
philanthropies are going to measure
results for their grant program they're
going to make commitments to outcomes
funds that pay out on social impact
bonds and development impact bonds when
the outcomes are reached and they're
going to invest from their endowment a
certain percentage we're asking for 10%
now in investment opportunities that
have the right balance of risk return
and impact you look at the disruption to
the business model of entrepreneurs
businesses are going to raise capital on
the basis of achieving financial and
social environmental goals you look at
the disruption at the level of social
sector organizations they're going to be
able to build a balance sheet we already
see six not-for-profit service delivery
providers in the UK with sales of more
than 50 million pounds I don't know if
you saw the figures in the Dan pilota
TED talk that in 25 years in the States
50,000 businesses
made it through 50 million of sales and
only 144 not-for-profits so you have
disruption coming to social sector
organizations that can scale and fund
innovation and you have disruption for
governments which begin to measure
outcomes instead of just paying for
inputs and which attract capital to fund
innovation from investors we take the
risk of failure because they're
motivated by a blended financial and
social return so for me this impact
revolution is going to be as pervasive
as the tech revolution has been and it's
going to be led by the likes of you
you're the ones who are going to
innovate and you're the ones who are
going to scale this in such a way that
we do a better job of improving people's
lives than we've been able to do until
now so I think some of our professors
like Matt Banach who teaches here and
Heidi and Charles will be quite
delighted with the fact they've just
reinforced all the teachings they've
they've been trying to force enough over
the past couple of weeks
what matt has been there has been my
partner one of my partner's very close
partners in the task force and now in
the global steering group of 13
countries plus the EU which had
succeeded the task force so Sir Ronald I
I get the privilege of asking the last
question and as you alluded to earlier
you used to be the president of the
Oxford Union so back in the day you're
in my seat inviting the thought leaders
to share their thoughts such as Bobby
Kennedy I was just wondering were there
any pearls of wisdom that particularly
resonated and stay with you that you
like to share with us today
I think it's right to be idealistic I
think when people say you shouldn't be
idealistic they're really concerned
about their ability to be successful and
to be idealistic at the same time and I
think the two are totally consistent I
got into venture capital
because I thought it was socially good
Britain had three million unemployed and
I thought it was a good thing to do and
it created a lot of jobs and it improved
competitiveness of the country and it
improved the average standard of living
but they really didn't bridge the gaps
between rich and poor what we've
discovered is that two slogans of my
generation growth will cure economic
ills and the quality of opportunity
don't out to be empty slogans for those
whom society leaves behind economic
growth creates an even bigger gap
between rich and poor and the quality of
opportunity is an empty phrase for
somebody born into a family where both
parents are unemployed and have a drug
habit unless we begin to focus on
improving the quality of our society our
societies are going to break apart we
already see major divides occurring
within our cities within our countries
within within regions and I think the
zeitgeist today
unlike the zeitgeist in 1977 to 69 when
I was where you are sitting now which
was small is going to be beautiful and
innovation is going to come from
technology the zeitgeist today is being
impactful is going to be beautiful and
being impactful is going to change our
lives in the same way that technology
has done well on that positive note
please join me in thanking Sir Ronald